And now we turn to the next topic, which will
reveal to us that some hidden messages are
more surprising than others. After we implemented
the Frequent Words Problem, let's apply it
to real genomes and start from the replication
origin in the bacterium Vibrio cholerae.
And when we run our algorithms, it turns out
there are too many potential replication origins.
We actually find 4 frequent words.
Not to mention that we do not know yet whether
it's even statistically surprising to find
a 9-mer in a string of length 500 that appears
3 or more times.
So, which of these four [frequent words] represents
a real DnaA box, and which of them are just
statistical artifacts?
Well, in this case, it's actually possible
to figure out which of these 4 candidates
represents a real DnaA box because two of
them are very special.
They represent reverse complementary k-mers.
And here I showed that one of them actually
is a perfect reverse complement to another.
You may think that I am cheating because if
you look at the red 9-mers shown in the box
and the red 9-mer shown in the bottom slide
of this slide, they are different.
But remember, DNA has a direction, and strands
run in opposite directions.
So when we look at the string starting from
TAC (red string) we should actually read it
in the opposite direction, and then everything
would make sense.
So, hidden message found!...
And it is extremely surprising, almost unbelievable,
to find one word appearing six times, either
as itself, or as a reverse complement in a
short string.
So it reinforces our belief that we are onto
something.
And after we have done it, let's try something
else. Let's try to find hidden message in
Thermotoga petrophila, which is a bacteria
enjoying life in very hot environment, about
80 degrees Celsius.
Maybe we should simply look for these two
k-mers that we found before, but unfortunately,
they are not even there.
So, it looks like we need to run our Frequent
Words Problem again, and in this case we actually
find 6 frequent words, which tells us that
probably different genomes have different
hidden messages.
It complicates our life quite a lot because
for thousands of bacteria, we need to search
for newer and newer hidden messages.
But with the Frequent Words Problem, we are
at least armed with algorithms to do it for
any bacterium.
Now, let' consult with Ori-Finder to choose
which one of these six 9-mers represents the
real DnaA box.
It tells us that it looks like the one shown
on this slide.
And we learned therefore how to find frequent
words and hopefully DnaA boxes in any bacteria.
But wait a second, I told you how to find
DnaA boxes as frequent words if the origin
of replication is known.
But of course, the position of the origin
of replication, this 500-nucleotide region
where we look for frequent words, is unknown.
How possibly can we find it?
Remember, we have to find this 500-nucleotide
region in a genome that may be millions of
nucleotides long.
And, let's resort to the idea that I call
"clumps" or "clusters" of hidden message to
solve this problem.
So, what we have been doing before?
We assumed that the replication origin region
that may be 500 nucleotides long is known.
And in this replication origin, we were finding
frequent words, for example, in this window
we found a frequent word that appears 4 times,
so it gives us a hint that maybe it is a DnaA
box.
But if we don't know the replication origin,
what should we do?
Maybe we should look at all possible windows
in the genome, and if in a particular window,
we find some frequent words appearing many
times, it's a hint that maybe we found a replication
origin.
Let's define "short" as something of length
L and many as "at least t times" and that's
defines the notion of an (L,t)-clump -- it's
a k-mer that appears in a window of length
L at least t times.
And now you have a new Rosalind challenge
which is the Clump Finding Problem.
You are a given a string called Genome, an
integer k (the length of k-mer), an integer
L (window length), and t (number of patterns
in a clump).
In Output, you have to find all (L,t)-clumps
in the genome.
And we hope that every (L,t)-clump will point
us to the location of replication origin.
Let's assume that you solved it and let's
run it. Let's run it on E. coli genome, the
workhorse of bacterial genomics.
Here is the result: we find about two thousand
potential (500,3)-clumps, which means 500-length
windows where there are frequent words appearing
3 or more times.
It is just too many. It's absolutely unclear
how to choose the real replication origin
among them.
What should we do? Should we give up? Let's
try to develop new ideas and see how we can
move further despite the fact that we seem
to be stuck.